nicosia is the European Union's
southernmost capital we're here to meet
Mario soooo noelia and he suggested
getting together at the cypress
handicraft center which promotes local
wares Mario's has been coming here since
he was a child the passion and everyday
sounds that are a part of his
compositions were absorbed in places
like this this cannon was a gang zhi
what we'll do here isn't music in the
proper sense but if you give it
structure in a musical context with
other instruments then you bring it to
life maintained and compass 11 we
venture to another of the city centers
traditional workshops so the composer
can scout out more inspirational sounds
everyday sounds in music are why we
first got to know Mario's we met him in
Germany back in 2011 he'd composed a
piece and titled Otto symphonic to
commemorate the automobiles 125th
anniversary
his work combined an orchestra with the
sounds of 80 automobiles the symphony
went on to win international acclaim
the conductor has been living in Germany
for several years now so he particularly
enjoys a visit home and a walk along the
venetian fortress walls encircling the
old town Venice ruled Cyprus in the 16th
century more of the islands history is
documented in the levant east Municipal
Museum living in Germany has made
mario's more appreciative of Cypriot
traditions in here a verified stayed in
Cyprus I wouldn't be the way I am now I
wouldn't be so proud Lisa preoccupying
always lived here habit of nikka she has
three hundred and ten thousand residents
75,000 live in the Turkish Cypriot north
nicosia is Europe's only divided capital
but more recently the 40-year old
division has been overshadowed by the
economic crisis supernet Cyprus has been
making negative headlines in recent
months how do you deal with that as or
if been in sets personally I'm furious
in the media there's been a negative
view of the current situation in Cyprus
but the impression you get that we the
people of Cyprus are angry at Germany
that just isn't the truth folica Alf get
a piece this is neat people are angry at
the politicians the politicians have
been putting a financial squeeze on
ordinary people here oh and [ __ ] it
pressed many of the houses along the
border in Nicosia stand empty their
occupants were expelled like Maria's his
parents the border has been open for the
past 10 years but Mario's has only
crossed at once despite his reluctance
we persuade him to accompany us into the
Turkish sector an emotional experience
for him
a few minutes later we strike up a
conversation with Turkish guitar maker
or a new med lab he and his wife give us
a quick tour but to originally hailed
from Istanbul but have been living in
the Casilla for a few years now they
show us the famous cell Amir mosque it
was originally a cathedral but after the
city came under Ottoman control in the
1570s it was converted into a mosque we
part company with a promise to come
again soon it took just two hours two
arrays a number of stereotypes
day has turned in tonight and it's time
to reminisce about the 2011 automotive
symphony but gave the conductor a major
career boost
if Benny my so very fit them that since
then people have been saying to me now
that you've done that you can do
practically anything regardless of size
for matter stage and it's been a
crowning achievement going godless Mario
CEO noelia is planning to stage a
project on a similar scale at nikka
CEA's disused airport two years from now
after living abroad for so many years
he's looking forward to giving something
back to his homeland